zwei gewinner paare keine entscheidung
im rennen um den spd parteivorsitz
müssen die durstewitz scholz und esken
walter borjans in die stichwahl
außenminister maß in heikler mission in
ankara trifft er seinen türkischen
kollegen der fordert hilfe aus
deutschland um flüchtlinge zurück nach
syrien zu bringen und sensationssieg zum
saisonstart in sölden die erst 17
jährige neuseeländerin alles robinson
rast beim riesenslalom allen davon
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten abend und
willkommen zum nachrichtenüberblick an
diesem samstag kristin otto ist auch
dabei für den sport mit einigen
überraschungen guten abend aufregender
tag für die spd
wochenlang hatten sich die
kandidatenpaare für den parteivorsitz in
23 regionalkonferenzen der basis
vorgestellt heute das ergebnis über die
hälfte der genossen haben gewählt aber
keines der paare kam über 50 prozent
und so müssen jetzt klara geywitz und
vizekanzler olaf scholz gegen norbert
walter borjans und saskia esken antreten
in der stichwahl um das höchste amt der
spd das seit jahren einem schleudersitz
gleicht 1999 wird gerhard schröder für
fünf jahre vorsitzender dann ein
wechselt nach dem anderen innerhalb von
vier jahren vier wechsel 2009 eine
längere phase unter sigmar gabriel
insgesamt acht jahre bevor dann martin
schulz und andrea nahles an ihrer partei
scheitern
jetzt soll es zum ersten mal eine
doppelspitze richten das montag seit den
frühen morgenstunden wurde ausgezählt in
der spd-zentrale knapp 430.000
mitglieder waren aufgerufen ihre stimme
online oder per briefwahl abzugeben
am ende beteiligten sich 53 prozent eine
eher ernüchternde zahl ein klaren sieger
gibt es nicht zwei kandidaten paare
müssen in die stichwahl auf saskia esken
und norbert walter borjans entfielen 44
1967 stimmen das entspricht einem anteil
von 21,04 prozent auf klara geywitz und
olaf scholz entfielen 48 1473 stimmen
das entspricht einem anteil von 22,6 8
prozent
scholz und klara geywitz gehen also in
die stichwahl beide gelten als nüchtern
und pragmatisch der vizekanzler steht
wie kaum ein anderer in der spd für die
große koalition und will bis zum ende
der legislaturperiode weiterregieren
jetzt geht es darum wie wir die spd so
stark machen kann dass sie ihre rolle in
deutschland spielen kann als partei die
für fairness und gerechtigkeit steht und
darum geht's ja sie wollen das
gegenmodell sein
saskia esken und norbert walter borjans
früher finanzminister in nordrhein
westfalen
beide stehen der großen koalition sehr
kritisch gegenüber nämlich dass man
klare ansagen machen muss wie wir in
unserem land für gerechtigkeit sorgen
dass wir nicht einknicken vom mächtigen
gruppen die interesse haben es
vielleicht ein bisschen anders zu
gestalten das heißt also dass wir
sozialdemokratie in der spd auch wieder
erkennbar machen und menschen die
glaubwürdigkeit der spd zurückgeben
mitte november also geht es in die
stichwahl und damit vielleicht auch um
die frage ob die große koalition über
das jahr hinaus noch bestand haben wird
der controller bennati in der
spd-zentrale in berlin was bedeutet
dieses ergebnis jetzt für die große
koalition und für den vizekanzler
was bedeutet es zumindest die ganz große
konfrontation heute ausgeblieben ist es
sind keine beinharten gegner der großen
koalition in die stichwahl gekommen
sondern es wird eher einen moderaten
kampf um die frage gehen wie gegeben wie
wird es jetzt weitergehen olaf scholz
das haben wir eben schon gehört steht
mit seiner partnerin für ein ganz klares
weiter so bis zum ende der
legislaturperiode das andere duo hat
sich kritisch geäußert hat auch gesagt
wir müssen perspektivisch raus aus der
großen koalition aber man hört von
beiden doch auch immer wieder signale
die da sagten nichts überstürzen das
wird also jetzt sehr spannend zu sehen
wie es hier im wenn es auf die stichwahl
zu geht in dem weiteren wahlkampf
aussehen wird wie die beiden sich da
positionieren werden aber wie gesagt die
ganz große konfrontation ist
ausgeblieben interessant ist auch noch
dass olaf scholz seinen promi bonus der
ihm hier angerechnet wurde nicht ganz so
umsetzen konnte das ergebnis zwischen
den beiden erstplatzierten das ist
gerade mal die gerade mal einen guten
prozentpunkt auseinander
also das wird ein sehr enges rennen
jetzt um die frage wer dann am ende als
sieger daraus hervor geht bis ende
november wird das ganze noch dauern
dann haben wir ein weiteres ergebnis und
dann erst wissen wir welches du die spd
in zukunft führen wird
danke schön stark und alle penalty aus
berlin
die landtagswahl in thüringen morgen
könnte die krise der spd noch
verschärfen nach dem letzten zdf
politbarometer kommt sie dort nur noch
auf ein einstelliges ergebnis und damit
wackelt auch die bisherige rot rot grüne
koalition in thüringen unter dem ersten
linken ministerpräsidenten bodo ramelow
dabei ist der regierungschef beliebt
eine mehrheit der thüringer will demnach
bodo ramelow als regierungschef behalten
zudem könnte aber die afg deutlich
zulegen
im wahlstudio in erfurt ist bettina
schausten bettina was ist das spannende
morgen in thüringen
ja es ist diese wirklich besondere
ausgangslage hier in thüringen bodo
ramelow kann hier viel landesvater bonus
in die wahl einbringen und könnte der
linken morgen hier einen geradezu
historischen wahlsieg verschaffen und
dann gibt es auf der ganz anderen
politischen seite den vertreter des
extrem rechten flügel
der fdr können ja selbst innerhalb
seiner partei umstritten ist das alt d
ergebnis aber wird sich hier wohl
verdoppeln ja und dann hat die
klassische mitte schwer gerade die
berliner gruppe parteien cdu und spd
müssen wieder mit einem dämpfer rechnen
das alles macht dann die
regierungsbildung kompliziert gut
möglich dass es für keine variante
reicht nicht einmal für eine vierer
konstellation sondern es auf eine
minderheitsregierung hinauslaufen muss
also viel spannender geht's eigentlich
tatsächlich nicht für melden uns morgen
hier aus dem zdf wahlstudio in erfurt ab
17 40 bis morgen genau dankeschön
bettina schausten heikle dienstreise da
war das heute für außenminister heiko
maas er war in der türkei um auf eine
dauerhafte waffenruhe in nordsyrien zu
drängen
weil maß den türkischen einmarsch dort
scharf kritisiert hatte ihn präsident
erdogan als dilettanten beschimpft und
der türkische außenminister warnte maß
per twitter auf deutsch du bist uns
immer willkommen aber nicht mit
erhobenem zeigefinger wer die türkei
belehrt muss mit einer entsprechenden
antwort rechnen kein leichter besuch für
heiko maas in ankara
es sei besser miteinander als
übereinander zu sprechen sagt der
außenminister über das verhältnis zum
schwierigen partner trotz
ernstzunehmende differenzen bleibe die
türkei ein enger nato partner
so maß beim versuch einer annäherung man
müsse nach dem türkisch russischen
abkommen jetzt neuen realitäten in
syrien ins auge sehen wichtig sei der
schutz der zivilbevölkerung auf die
vereinbarung von sochi ist es für uns
von überragender bedeutung dass wir zu
allererste sicherstellen dass die
waffenruhe hält und auch verlängert wird
die türkische präsenz in syrien dürfen
nicht von dauer sein forderte maas
cavusoglu nannte die schwere kritik aus
deutschland ungerecht auch an der
geplanten rückführung von flüchtlingen
sowohl russland als auch die usa hätten
die türkische militär operation
akzeptiert wir werden auch künftig
sicherstellen dass flüchtlinge nur
freiwillig
und unter sicheren bedingungen nach
syrien zurückkehren wir erwarten aber
dabei die hilfe der internationalen
gemeinschaft vor allem deutschlands
unter ihnen
deutlicher wurde heute staatspräsident
erdogan wenn europa bei der rückführung
von zwei millionen flüchtlingen nicht
helfe werde er die grenzen öffnen sagte
erdogan
dann sollen sie doch nach europa ziehen
[Applaus]
sieht sich in einer position der stärke
der vorschlag von
verteidigungsministerin kramp
karrenbauer für eine international
geschützte sicherheitszone war kein
thema cavusoglu nannte das vorhaben
wenig realistisch unser korrespondent
jörg brase ist an der türkisch syrischen
grenze wie wahrscheinlich ist es denn
überhaupt das tatsächlich syrische
flüchtlinge in diese zone zurückgeführt
werden können
also ich halte das für nicht besonders
wahrscheinlich heute sind syrische
regierungstruppen bis zur stadt ras
allein vorgedrungen an der türkischen
grenze die militärs von präsident assad
bewegen sich immer weiter richtung
norden in die pufferzone und vor diesen
truppen ist er nun ein großer teil der
syrer richtung türkei und europa
geflohen und dass die nun bereit wären
sich in einer pufferzone anzusiedeln
freiwillig dort anzusiedeln aus der die
wenigsten von ihnen stammen und die
zudem von teilen in teilen von ersatz
truppen kontrolliert wird das kann ich
mir nicht vorstellen genauso wenig dass
diese zone irgendwann mal von un
blauhelm truppen kontrolliert werden
könnte
das wird russland mit seinem veto im
sicherheitsrat verhindern die russen
haben es ja gerade erst geschafft dass
ihr waffenbruder assad oben im norden
wieder fuß fassen kann
präsident erdogan will dort aber
flüchtlinge ansiedeln wir haben soeben
gehört der hat auch noch mal richtung
europa gedroht aber wie gesagt dass
flüchtlinge dort freiwillig und sicher
zurückkehren wollen oder können halte
ich für zweifelhaft und das wird glaube
ich sehr schwer sei nur noch wie viele
konflikte sorgen zwischen europa und der
türkei
vielen dank für diese einschätzung aus
der türkei jörg brase
im osten syriens verstärken die usa
wieder ihre truppen offiziell um zu
verhindern dass die ölfelder dort wieder
in die hände des falls aus russischer
sicht verfolgt washington aber einen
anderen plan
das verteidigungsministerium in moskau
spricht von staatlichem banditentum
unter us schutz werde öl gefördert und
illegal außer landes geschafft in chile
treiben steigende lebenshaltungskosten
und niedrige renten und löhne immer mehr
menschen auf die straße im ganzen land
versammelten sich mehr als eine million
menschen und forderte von präsident
piñera soziale reformen
dieser reagierte am mittag und kündigte
an sein kabinett umbilden zu wollen und
bat alle minister um rücktritt im
benachbarten argentinien wird morgen ein
neuer präsident gewählt und es könnte
einen machtwechsel geben
der konservative präsident mauricio
macri wollte die armut bekämpfen doch
seine bilanz ist ernüchternd die
inflation ist hoch die wirtschaft am
boden
mehr als ein drittel der argentinier ist
arm das will sein mitte links
herausforderer alberto fernandez ändern
er wird von der umstrittenen ex
präsidentin cristina kirchner
unterstützt christoph reckert berichtet
die bilder sollen wird zum
wahlkampfabschluss bietet argentiniens
konservativer präsident marc rauch
einmal alles auf in seiner hochburg
buenos aires in den umfragen ist er
abgeschlagen doch er kämpft weiter
vor uns stehen noch große
herausforderungen
aber es kann nicht die antwort sein
jetzt jene zurück zu holen die uns mit
ihren leeren versprechungen all die
jahre im stich gelassen haben gemeint
sind die gegner aus dem lager der
peronisten alberto fernandez und ex
präsidentin cristina kirchner sie vor
allem bewegt die gemüter kandidiert nur
als vize und es doch für viele die
eigentliche alternative zu amtsinhaber
max wir wollen die argentinier von ihrem
schmerz befreien nie wieder diese
politik nie wieder neoliberalismus
verspricht sie dabei endete ihre von
misswirtschaft und korruption geprägte
präsidentschaft erst vor vier jahren die
peronisten wurden abgewählt
doch marie konnte sein wichtigstes
versprechen nicht halten
statt aufschwung erlebt argentinien eine
schwere krise inflation armut hunger
erreichen traurige rekorde
selbst in buenos aires begegnet uns das
elend überall
der 15 jährige nicolas lebt mit seiner
schwester und ihrem freund auf der
straße befährt eine gute ernährung ich
bekomme nicht was andere 15-jährige zu
essen bekommen wir hungern so viele
hungern hier wirtschaftsexperten halten
makris reformkurs langfristig dennoch
für den richtigen
doch für millionen argentinier ist der
preis schlicht zu hoch als dass sie noch
einmal marco werden dürfte in
kalifornien fressen sich weiterhin
mehrere große waldbrände durch land und
ortschaften
ein problem sind marode oberirdische
stromleitungen bei starkem wind drohen
die masten umzustürzen und so weitere
feuer zu entfachen
deshalb wird vorsichtshalber der strom
abgestellt mit unabsehbaren folgen für
hunderttausende ines trams berichtet
[Musik]
lauf ruf diese mutter als sie mit ihren
kindern von zu hause fliegt die flammen
bereits ganz nah
50.000 menschen mussten allein in
südkalifornien ihre häuser verlassen
hitze trockenheit und starke winde
fachen die brände in der nähe von los
angeles an
bisher konnte die feuerwehr gerade erst
fünf prozent eindämmen
unser haus ist einfach in flammen
aufgegangen ich weiß nicht ob da oben
jemand ist um das feuer zu löschen
die ganze struktur hat gebrannt vier
weitere brände wüten in der
nordkalifornischen weinbauregion die
kleinstadt gainesville schwer zerstört
eventuell haben beschädigte oberirdische
stromleitungen die brände entfacht der
gouverneur wirft dem größten
energieunternehmen kaliforniens geldgier
und missmanagement vor
dieser habgier hat zu einer mangelnden
sorgfalt geführt sie haben ihr stromnetz
weder modernisiert noch in den boden
verlegt sie haben schlicht wächst ihren
job nicht gemacht um die gefahr durch
marode leitungen zu bannen schaltet der
energieversorger rund 200.000 haushalten
vorübergehend den strom ab die winde
werden derweil bis sonntag nochmals
zunehmen
zurück nach europa zu einem ganz anderen
thema heute nacht wird nämlich wieder an
der uhr gedreht und das bleibt wohl auch
erstmal so denn würde die zeitumstellung
abgeschafft dann gäbe es in europa einen
flickenteppich mit unterschiedlichen
zeitzonen fürchten viele eu-staaten sagt
die finnische ratspräsidentschaft
und so bleibt zunächst alles beim alten
heute nacht um 3 uhr wird die uhr um
eine stunde zurückgestellt dadurch ist
es morgens früher hell und abends früher
dunkel
winterzeit wintersport die alpine saison
hat begonnen christian gleich mit einem
knaller richtig cool muss man sagen 17
jahr blondes haar eine teenagerin aus
neuseeland sorgt zum weltcup auftakt für
eine sportliche sensationelles robinson
gewinnt den traditionellen riesenslalom
von sölden vor usa micaela chefin eines
robinson verblüfft mit diesem
paukenschlag sich selbst und die gesamte
fachwelt völlig unbeschwert und mit
vollem risiko bewältigt sie den schweren
kurs im ötztal und setzt sich an die
spitze
nach ihr die olympiasiegerin michaela
schütteln aber die us amerikanerin kann
ihren vorsprung aus dem ersten lauf
nicht verteidigen
robinson schlägt die haushohe favoritin
und gewinnt als erster neuseeländerin
einen riesenslalom weltcup für die
wm-zweite viktoria rebensburg schreibt
diesmal mit rang 13 nur eine nebenrolle
rekordmeister bayern münchen hat
vorläufig die tabellenspitze der fußball
bundesliga erobert und mit seinem
treffer zum 2 1 gegen union berlin hat
robert lewandowski als bisher einziger
spieler in den ersten neun partien
mindestens einmal getroffen
keine tore im revier derby schalke
dortmund 0 0 freiburg leipzig 2 1 hertha
hoffenheim 23 erster saison erfolg für
paderborn 2 0 gegen düsseldorf
das abendspiel leverkusen bremen
ausführlich im aktuellen sportstudio
gestern mainz köln 3 2 1 morgen können
zunächst wolfsburg und später gladbach
an die tabellenspitze zurück und die
bayern oben wieder verdrängen
freiburg neuer zweiter nun vor dortmund
leipzig runter auf sechs vor schalke
aber auch da kann sich noch einiges
verschieden am tabellenende verlässt
mainz den keller dort holt hinter köln
und augsburg schlusslicht paderborn
etwas auf und im topspiel der zweiten
liga feier tabellenführer hamburger sv
einen 6 2-kantersieg gegen stuttgart der
vfb rutscht hinter bielefeld auf
tabellenplatz drei und neben fußball im
aktuellen sportstudio die weltbesten
triathleten die ironman gewinner anne
haug und jan frodeno zweites spiel gegen
olympiasieger kroatien zweiter knapper
sieg für die deutschen handballer binnen
vier tagen
mal vor heimischer kulisse anspannung ja
an hochspannung ist dieses em
vorbereitungsspiel kaum zu überbieten
nach einer klaren steigerung des
deutschen teams in durchgang zwei
gelingt kai häfner 28 sekunden vor
schluss das 24 23 gegen kroatien
und dann macht die dramaturgie einen
spieler zum matchwinner
denn in der schlusssekunde pariert der
überragende torhüter des thw kiel dario
quenstedt den wurf von matanovic und
sicher damit den knappen erfolg für das
deutsche team und die deutschen handball
frauen gewann ihren wm test gegen
kroatien am selber stelle mit 32 23 also
ganz souverän große überraschung im
halbfinale der rugby weltmeisterschaft
in japan
die engländer setzten sich zum ersten
mal auf großer bühne gegen die
legendären all blacks die
titelverteidiger aus neuseeland durch
mit 19 zu 7
riesen jubel über den ersten endspiel
einzog für england seit zwölf jahren und
die finalgegner werden morgen ermittelt
südafrika oder wales danke schön draußen
wird spürbar kälter in den nächsten
tagen dazu gleich mehr beim wetter von
austin telli claus kleber begrüßte gegen
viertel vor elf im heute journal
danke für ihr interesse haben sie noch
ein schönes wochenende und bis morgen
wenn sie mögen auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
einen schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter eine kaltfront
nähert sich von norden her sie liegt
quasi schon über norddeutschland und
zieht langsam südwärts voran sie sehen
es hier an diesen blauen farben
ja und die details dazu sehen
folgendermaßen aus regen gibt es schon
in der nacht und das wandert auch
langsam südwärts dazu gibt es kräftigen
südwestwind
ja und da kann auch stürmisch sein im
süden ist es etwas ruhiger und da bildet
sich sogar nebel temperaturen kind
zurück bis auf 4 grad im südosten und 14
grad in den östlichen landesteilen ja
und morgen im tagesverlauf zieht diese
kaltfront langsam südwärts voran und
bleibt am nachmittag etwa über der mitte
liegen und schon ja das wird es regen
geben und dazu wird es noch windig sein
es lässt aber bis zum abend nach im
süden gibt es viel sonnenschein die
temperaturen dazu lägen bei 22 grad noch
einmal im süden aber schauen sie auf den
nordwesten hier nur noch 12 bis 15 grad
die temperatur geht deutlich zurück und
in den nächsten tagen noch viel weiter
und zwar am montag 8 bis 12 grad im
süden regen und schauen sie auf die
nächsten tage mittwoch nur noch vier bis
elf grad
ein schöner abend